boa noite boa noite sejam todos muito
bem-vindos hoje nós temos um um conteúdo
muito especial né com uma pessoa muito
especial também todo mundo que tiver
chegando vai falando aonde é que vocês
estão Qual a especialidade de vocês
mandem aqui no chat para que a gente
possa começar a nossa união de hoje né
nosso bate-papo né com um doutor que vai
participar aqui com a gente vamos lá
Fran Sérgio boa
noite boa noite qual a sua especialidade
e da onde você está
falando enquanto isso eu vou iniciar
aqui a nossa apresentação para vocês já
entenderem sobre o que que a gente vai
falar aqui hoje tá
bom boa noite Geovana Boa noite
ginecologista
legal
endócrino legal Pessoal vocês vão gostar
do bate-papo de hoje vamos lá que que a
gente quer trazer para vocês hoje tá
isso daqui vocês não vão encontrar em
lugar nenhum Hoje a gente vai mostrar
como que o Dr farani faturou mais de
cinco dígitos em menos de duas semanas
após tirar a sua secretária do
atendimento online e utilizar a nossa
Inteligência Artificial humanizada ao
atender os seus Pass entes Tá bom então
é sobre isso que nós vamos falar hoje o
Dr farani vai participar aqui com a
gente ele vai mostrar para vocês o que
que ele fez tá E vocês vão entender isso
então como é que vai funcionar esse
encontro primeiro eu vou te mostrar quem
eu sou tá então vou me apresentar para
vocês e mostrar como foi que eu criei a
primeira Inteligência Artificial de
atendimento humanizado da Medicina eu
irei convidar o Dr farani para contar um
pouco mais sobre a experiência que ele
tem com a inteligência artificial E como
que ela mudou o atendimento do
consultório dele e os resultados também
e terceiro eu vou mostrar como
implementar essa inteligência artificial
dentro do seu consultório tá e eu sempre
gosto de alinhar com vocês a duração
média desse dessa nossa reunião que vai
em torno ali de 40 minutos tá então para
vocês se prepararem E ficarem atentos
nessa apresentação tá
bom meu nome é est Soares tá eu também
sou médica além de ser uma das maiores
especialistas em captação no nicho
médico tá eu já participei dos
bastidores de grandes players do mercado
Ou seja eu Já ajudei vários várias
pessoas dentro do mercado digital não
somente da parte médica a iniciarem seus
projetos a venderem né e aparecerem ali
na internet eu também sou CEO e
fundadora da vero e já foram mais de
sete dígitos fato atados dentro da
internet e eu desenvolvi a primeira
Inteligência Artificial humanizada de
atendimento na medicina Tá e por
conviver com médicos e ser médicas eu
comecei a perceber grande que grande
parte dos médicos sofria com a demora
durante o atendimento das suas
secretárias perdia muitos agendamentos
porque a secretária ela não sabia como
converter aqueles pacientes que chegavam
no
WhatsApp eles gastavam tempo treinando a
secretária comprando scripts treinando e
a conversão não aumentava além de pagar
altos salários né e ter uma alta
rotatividade porque toda vez que uma
secretária não alcançava o nível
esperado ou não convertia o esperado
mesmo pagando bonificações criando metas
para essas essas essas secretárias eles
precisavam mudar Tá certo então a um
alto salário uma alta rotatividade
também e foi a partir disso que após ir
para os Estados Unidos e conhecer o
funcionamento do atendimento médico lá
eu entendi que eles dividiam Isso em
duas formas diferentes tinham um
atendimento presencial que eles
utilizavam a secretária humana para
encantar os pacientes para focar no que
realmente importa na experiência
daquelas pessoas né Para que você
conseguisse fidelizar presencialmente os
seus pacientes entregando uma melhor
experiência do seu consultório e tinha a
parte online onde Quem fazia todo o
atendimento online desses médicos era
Inteligência Artificial e eu achei isso
incrível porque realmente o foco da sua
secretária presencial hoje deve ser a
experiência do seu paciente e o online
quando a gente tem várias pessoas
entrando em contato coloca a
inteligência artificial para fazer todo
esse atendimento humanizado E agendar de
uma forma automática sem que você
precise treinar essa pessoa o tempo
inteiro então foi isso que eu encontrei
dentro dos Estados Unidos e decidi
Trazer isso para dentro do Brasil e foi
assim que eu criei a primeira
Inteligência Artificial humanizada de
atendimento exclusiva para médicos aqui
dentro do Brasil e qual é o resultado
que a gente tem hoje a gente já
implementou em todos os estados
brasileiros tá são C centenas de médicos
e CLN
utilizando Tá além disso eu eu entendo
que hoje vocês já devem ter percebido né
estão vivenciando que a inteligência
artificial dentro do atendimento médico
virou notícia em todos os portais hoje
um médico ou uma clínica que não utiliza
a inteligência artificial sofre dentro
dos seus processos não somente dentro do
atendimento né então quem utiliza
Inteligência Artificial otimiza muito o
o seu tempo né e consegue ali
transformar também o atendimento dos
seus pacientes né então aqui eu trouxe
algumas notícias para né que eu imagino
que vocês já devem ter visto
também e hoje nós já estamos
revolucionando ao redor né aqui do
Brasil com a nossa Inteligência
Artificial
inédita e um desses médicos tá é o Dr
farani que eu vou convidar ele para
falar com vocês agora a aqui ao
vivo Oi oi farani tá conseguindo me
ouvir olá olá boa noite Estela tudo bem
escuto você me escuta bem tô escutando
eu vou só vou tirar aqui a apresentação
pra gente conseguir ver você aê
Maravilha tudo bom Dr farani é um prazer
ter você aqui com a gente né eu falei um
pouquinho com você Falei que né o
resultado que você teve com a nossa
Inteligência Artificial mas melhor do
que eu para falar é convidando você para
est aqui com a gente então Doutor por
favor se apresente brevemente para que
as pessoas saibam quem você é e o que
que você
faz perfeito né antes disso eu quero
parabenizar a todos e todas que estão
aqui nesse momento né um período de
carnaval E por coincidência quando eu
participei do meu webinar eu estava
viajando também em férias né em família
na na Europa na época do Natal né e
tirei um período né um tempo para
assistir e ouvir o que a ela tinha para
falar e não me arrependi nenhum um pouco
né Muito pelo contrário né tô aqui hoje
com com vocês né Eu sou Mateus faran sou
médico for faculdade pública né famem
interior de São Paulo né minha formação
ela foi toda direcionada para ir paraos
Estados Unidos mas acabei mudando a rota
né continuei no Brasil e tive que me
Reinventar né encontrar né um caminho
aqui para ser diferente tá para fazer
diferente e de forma ética né Sem chala
nismo sem vender fórmulas prontas né E E
por aí vai que nem o luí tá comentando
Luiz Gustavo né todo mundo vende a
Fórmula Mágica né aqui não é formala
mágica tá muito pelo contrário é algo
bem bem alacar né e a ia Ela traz isso
pra gente
tá perfeito se você se eu fosse o médico
assistindo essa Live agora porque que eu
deveria prestar atenção no que você vai
dizer DR faran perfeito aproveitando até
o gancho aqui do luí né porque primeiro
não há Fórmula Mágica que vai aumentar o
dígito de vocês muito pelo contrário
isso aqui é só pense num carro de Need
For Speed né um carro de veló curiosa é
só um
aqui tá é uma forma de você impulsionar
o motor que tá funcionando bem se vocês
micos não são bons não adianta né a não
vai fazer milagre n me escutem porque
isso vai mudar a vida de vocês só por
isso vai mudar completamente o jogo para
quem quer fazer algo diferente para quem
não quer uma fórmula mágica para quem
quer realmente ser um médico fora da
curva legal e me fala um pouquinho hoje
o seu atendimento ele é focado em qual
queixa do seu paciente O que que você
foca hoje
aí bele hoje me atendimento ele é focado
num subnicho da medicina esportiva que é
o nicho de emagrecimento sobretudo tá e
controle hormonal né que seria nicho da
endocrinologia mas eu não falo que
endocrinologia porque eu não tenho RQ de
endocrino no Brasil e falo isso
abertamente né não é um subnicho só que
eu que eu abarco né então são pacientes
que T queixas tanto quanto urgentes né
pacientes procrastinadores também certo
modo sabe que isso é interessante porque
muitas pessoas acreditam que não não
conseguem ter resultado porque não tem o
RQ e você acabou de trazer que mesmo sem
tem resultado né
ah dentro do seu consultório Então isso
é muito interessante tá sim e sem fazer
sem fazer soro tá sem ficar empurrando
implante para paciente sem ficar
vendendo fórmulas injetáveis protocolos
injetáveis nada disso Isso que é o
melhor e me fala uma coisa antes de você
conhecer a nossa tecnologia como era o
do seu consultório antes como como era
essa rotina de
atendimento era bem engessada porque a
secretária por mais que eu tentasse
treiná-la elaborasse scripts elaborasse
passo a passo ela não conseguia fazer o
principal que era converter o paciente
capitar é muito fácil a questão toda é
conversão se você não tem uma pessoa bem
treinada então eu acab eu acabava tendo
que assumir Às vezes a função da
secretária n ela começar uma conversa
com o lid com potencial paciente e eu
ter que ir conduzir aquilo ali porque
ela não ia conseguir direcionar é então
era muito muito travado muito travado o
processo só quando era Alguém já bem
indicado né super indicado já E olha que
os meu o meu até então meus pacientes
são eram quase todos orgânicos né Eu
comecei o tráfego justamente com junto
com a com a Estela antes eu não fazia
tráfego tá e ainda assim era difícil
então era bem bem travado o fixo o que
que mais te incomodava
nessa forma antiga que você fazia né
você me falou que você tinha que colocar
a mão né você que tinha que colocar a
mão porque a sua secretária não
conseguia converter esses contatos em
pacientes Então me diga o que que te
incomodava primeiro que eu sabia que eu
tava fora da estatística ideal de tempo
de resposta para você conseguir ver uma
venda né então sabia que tava muito
muito muito fora disso segundo qualquer
coisinha que fugisse a o feijão com
arroz a secretária não sabia responder
quea tinha que travar o fluxo terceiro
que era basicamente um cop cola né o o
futuro paciente ele manda querendo saber
preço basicamente né a aí a secretária
vai fala ó Dr farani é formado em
faculdade pública tal fez extensão fora
do país e acabou a consulta é tanto isso
aí é péssimo e todo mundo faz isso né
então assim era era mais do mesmo e eu
odeio Ser Mais do Mesmo né Eu gosto de
ser diferente porque eu penso que você
tem que ser diferente né não existe não
tem você não tem escolha ou você é
diferente Ou você não é nada né é
basicamente isso é verdade é verdade e
me conta uma coisa Dr faran você já
testou outras soluções antes para que
melhorasse a conversão da sua
secretária sim eu tentei elaborar
scripts né fazer cursos de vendas cursos
para para secretárias eu fui atrás até
de automações mais baratas né de
chatbots né e não adiantava Não
adiantava entendi é o o que eu vejo
muitas pessoas falando é Ah eu criei o
script comprei o script treinei a
secretária mas ela continua enviando
sempre as mesmas mensagens quando foge
um pouquinho daquilo que a gente
construiu no Script ela tem que me
procurar ela não sabe como conduzir né
então Imagino que isso aconteceu com
você também ex me fala uma coisa como é
que você nos conheceu e o o que que te
fez decidir em né aplicar essa
tecnologia dentro do seu
consultório certo eu conheci vocês
porque eu já tinha decidido criar O que
vocês estão fazendo né hoje E aí
consequentemente como eu tava
pesquisando min chat várias ferramentas
de programação de a automaticamente né o
o seu o seu tráfego chegou até mim né E
aí eu te conheci inicialmente eu tive
várias objeções Me cadastrei no web des
cadastrei cadastrei de novo né pensei em
ir desistir entrei na hora saí voltei de
novo né então tive muita muita objeção
porque eu pensava que seria mais uma
Fórmula Mágica né ah que o que H que né
mais o mais do mesmo sabe isso que eu
pensava não sabia que que era tão algo
tão bom n tão bem tão bem desenhado e
tão barato inclusive
tá legal eu gostei do que você falou da
Fórmula má Qual foi o então que você
percebeu que não era uma Fórmula Mágica
que era algo real
mesmo quando eu parei para te ouvir n
porque antes de eu assistir a webinar
não dava para diferir diferenciar uhum
não
dava Legal vamos falar de número né Eu
acho que é isso que a maioria das
pessoas elas querem ouvir depois que
você implementou a inteligência
artificial seu consultório Quais foram
os primeiros impactos que isso gerou
para você e pro pro seu atendimento e
pro seu
consultório primeiro impacto foi
justamente agendamento né conversão eu
peguei esse período de
pré-carnaval que em tese tem bastante
procura tem muito tem muito curioso e
tudo mais e consultas que eu não
conseguiria de forma alguma converter
era era eu tava atendendo por exemplo de
manhã um paciente né sei lá oito sete
tava no sétimo paciente do dia e eu
descobria que a ia né descobria não ao
longo do dia a ia tinha aado mais dois
pro mesmo dia por exemplo um outro pro
outro dia de manhã então assim ia
empilhando né esses esses pacientes que
eu não conseguiria converter porque a
minha secretária n ia saberia nem falar
fora o horário né horário questão do
horário comercial né de 8 à 18 tudo mais
eu tive paciente que mandou mensagem 18
horas 20 horas tava no meu consultório
para ser atendido presencial né então
assim nunca quiso sem aá seria possível
tipo nunca impossível
impossível então o que você achou que o
que você viu que mais impactou foi a
questão da rapidez do atendimento da
qualidade do atendimento que gera essa
conversão rápida também né Exatamente
exatamente porque assim por mais que que
eu tivesse o o meu tráfego né ele foi
muito focado em Google né inicialmente
né então assim a gente não fez ainda né
um tráfego tão tão forte para dizer que
eu tive leads em massa e tudo mais não
foi realmente a questão da qualidade
mesmo do do material sabe da da Iá né de
ser muito bem
leg tá muito bem desenhada
muito bom e agora falando da sua
comparando na verdade com a sua
secretária tradicional o que que mudou
no dia a dia do seu
atendimento mudou que minha secretária
tradicional passei a ser muito mais
eficiente e eficaz porque ela deixou de
fazer algo que ela não tinha competência
para fazer que era conversão de paciente
ela passou a fazer o que uma secretária
humana faz que é administrar os
pacientes no dia a dia resolver coisas
pontuais lembrete
lista de pendências e tudo mais mas o a
questão da conversão agendamento
lembrete de paciente e tudo mais não tem
que usar secretária humana fazer isso
humana é para fazer o que a máquina não
faz pô se usar sua secretária para ficar
agendando o paciente é jogar tempo da
secretária no lixo pô no lixo Isso é
verdade é o que eu falo muito pro
pessoal Existem certas coisas que a
gente consegue colocar uma inteligência
artificial para fazer que é o caso do
atendimento né para fazer toda essa
parte de agenda
e deixar ali a secretária porque que ela
deve fazer melhor que é a experiência
presencial daqueles pacientes
exatamente online também o tempo que ela
é perder respondendo curioso ela atenção
ao seu paciente pô Ó que coisa linda ex
examente perfeito Dr farani vamos você
consegue mostrar pra gente na prática o
funcionamento da ia porque eu acho que
isso vai ser muito interessante pro
pessoal que tá aqui também você consegue
compartilhar acredito que sim pronto eu
vou abrir aqui agora eu vou vai depender
só da internet que eu tô em eu tô
viajando agora eu tô em eu tô em onde é
que eu tô mesmo São Miguel dos Milagres
São Miguel dos Milagres agora mas eu tô
abrindo aqui o z
arpon e aí vai vai funcionar a internet
resolveu ajudar você sabe como
compartilha a tela certo Sei sei sim
legal tá Tá dominado essa parte eu tô só
Fabrina conversa aqui enquanto o Dr
farani ele vai compartilhar a tela ele
tá separando né direitinho para mostrar
pra gente vão enviando aqui as dúvidas
que vocês têm tá Lindaura falou boa
noite sou de Feira de Santana pertinho
Lindaura seja muito
bem-vinda Duval seja muito bem-vindo
Mateus seja muito
bem-vindo boa noite
pessoal boa noite Val
abrindo
aqui perguntou e para quem tem
secretári Paes o que pode fazer para
aumentar o número de pacientes vamos lá
que que ela consegue fazer a sua
secretara ela consegue atender 20 30
pessoas ao mesmo tempo com a mesma
qualidade e rapidez Então porque quando
a gente tá falando de atendimento eu
preciso atender aquelas pessoas antes de
5 minutos ter uma boa conversão eu
preciso ter a qualidade do meu
atendimento então sempre prestando
atenção no que o paciente tá falando
Chamando pelo nome trazendo essa
qualidade tá e eu preciso ser eficaz
também você acredita que a sua
secretária conseguiria falar com 30 40
pessoas ao mesmo tempo isso é algo que a
inteligência artificial ela faz também
tá boa noite boa noite Certo boa noite
Maria Priscila
Maravilha pode compartilhar Então tá
deixa compartilhar
[Música]
aqui pert teleconsulta em alergia e
dermatologia Como pode me
ajud sim conseguindo ver então pess tem
conversas aqui basicamente aqui ó para
iniciarmos seu atendimento Qual o seu
nome Mateus né Isso aí a já tá
respondendo a minha tá programada para
para 10 segundos né de tempo de resposta
boa você tem pram até isso a gente
consegue configurar também tá pessoal o
tempo de
resposta hum
minha internet tá um pouco lenta isso
acaba dificultando um
pouco ainda não processou
aqui ainda não enviu a mensagem né É
porque eu acho que nosso
qu
é Tá vendo você vê que ó como é que tá
Tá vendo
uhum faz parte
compartilhando faz parte a internet é
assim mesmo mas você viu que ela já
respondeu aqui ó para iniciar o
atendimento Qual o seu nome o mandei o
oi aqui ela
já já respondeu
boa aí ó respondeu aqui ó consegue ler
rapidinho PR gente porque tá um
pouquinho embaçado respondeu Claro claro
Mateus antes de falarmos sobre as
consult gostaria de saber em qual cidade
você está assim posso fornecer as
informações mais adequadas para você
Lembrando que eu atendo presencialmente
em em dois em dois estados né na Bahia e
em São Paulo né em Salvador em Marília
vou falar aqui eu tô em Salvador
né Salvador que ele vai puxar pro
presencial
Ah tá escrevendo ó meu temem espanhol
aqui né escribiendo
aí ótimo Mateus como você está Salvador
posso oferecer curas presenciais o
atendimento em curso Inicial que é o que
eu faço né eu faço um atendimento e uma
reavaliação n no primeiro momento e a
impedância aí ó desejo desejo
emagrecimento mas não posso gastar uma
fortuna
Então pessoal perceba que aá a primeira
coisa que ela fez foi perguntar como é
que ele tava para dar seguimento no
atendimento perguntou pelo nome então
ela sempre vai falar com o paciente
usando o nome do paciente no caso do Dr
farani aí ela precisou perguntar onde
está esse paciente porque a depender da
onde ele esteja poderia ter ser atendido
na Bahia em María ou
teleconsulta tá então por isso que ela
fez essa pergunta
antes aí tá vendo entendo uma entendo
mais resultados cons sustentáveis ainda
per de gordura você ganhará mais
motivação disciplina autoestima
garantindo que os resultados sejam
duradores a consulta Inicial junto com a
reavaliação tem preço inicial de R 800
que já inclui de impedância significa
que você que cara sairá por apenas R 400
aí se o valor for PR ocupação ela D
opção de parcelar aade de pagamento
parcelado um sinal 210 mais duas vezes 3
250 no cartão aí o que você acha disso
tá vendo tá assim bem bem legal né assim
não sei aí ó não sei sei se terei um bom
resultado né eu vou mandar isso aqui ver
se ela vai puxar para mim os resultados
dos
pacientes vamos ver o que que ela vai
falar tenho medo de
investir são coisas que os pacientes
falam geralmente né oente V com objeção
Ah não posso gastar Ah não não sei se
vou ter
resultado exatamente qual ela trabalha
dentro disso ela já escrevendo aí ó tá
vendo escribiendo
aí ó aí Ela traz provas sociais tá vendo
resultado de de mulheres né e de homens
que a gente segundo a gente seguindo as
nas do cfm a gente pode divulgar
resultado tá de antes e depois desde que
você não exponha né o paciente né então
assim eu tenho esses links que mostram
né resultados dos pacientes perfeito e e
ela traz aqui ó né resultado resultados
focados né não tem mais
confiança né então assim bem bem legal
né isso aqui só uma uma mostr né Essa aí
aqui faz faz muita
coisa muito bom contin aqui
interação ela manda áudio também quer
ver
ó áudio
aqui
legal faran Dr faran ainda tá aí ou
caiu Opa tá vendo a tela hein Tá vendo a
tela ou saiu não saiu a tela saiu foi
porque eu gravei o áudio aí por é por
isso que ela
saiu voltou voltou voltou Ah você enviou
um áudio legal que eu gravei isso eu
enviei o áudio né Isso dá para ver se se
enviou um
áudio envi o áudio aí ela tá gravando
áudio tá vendo ó gravando áudio grabando
áudio e ela sempre traz horários Você
pode ter 1000 horários na agenda ela vai
sempre filtrar horários para gerar
escassez Entendeu Legal então assim tem
isso também a pessoa que fala assim que
ah que eu tenho minha agenda eu tô
começando agora tenho um monte de
horário na agenda que não sei qu né a i
ela sabe fazer isso né ela ela filtra
isso a gente sempre faz aqui ah de
disponibilizar dois horários dentro da
disponibilidade do médico caso o
paciente ele não consiga naqueles dois
horários disponíveis a gente vai
liberando outros horários de acordo com
a preferência também do paciente
tá E aí ela tá gravando o áudio né
processando ela já vai enviar um áudio
pra gente né E você pode mandar um áudio
de um minuto que ela ela vai escutar o
áudio de um minuto e vai gravar um áudio
equivalente maravilha eu tenho um caso
aqui de um de um paciente
até um um possível paciente hoje que ele
mandou três áudios um minuto e aí a
gravou osos respondendo tudo certinho ó
a Aline perguntou podemos programar
respostas para todos os tipes de
tratamentos oferecidos na clínica é
possível fazer essa personalização sim
Aline é possível sim tá a e a ela 100%
personalizada para o seu caso né a gente
constrói uma do completo zero focando em
quem é você Qual sua especialidade O que
que você faz como funciona seu
atendimento Quais são os tratamentos que
você tem tá a Luciana perguntou quanto
tempo para programar e personalizar uma
inteligência
artificial leva em torno de 10 dias
úteis tá
como minha internet tá lenta ela não
recebeu ainda o áudio não tem problema
vou seguir aqui com algumas perguntas tá
pra gente
conseguir caminhar com com a nossa
entrevista aqui Dr faran vamos lá o que
que você diria para os médicos que ainda
não utilizam inteligência artificial no
seu atendimento
Oi que eu tinha Você pode repetir por
favor clar o que você diria para os
médicos que ainda não estão utilizando
inteligência artificial no seu
atendimento basicamente que vocês estão
para
trás porque in artificial não é não é
algo futurista é realidade pô tá
acontecendo aqui n exato momento Tô
mostrando para vocês e acontecendo né
Vocês estão para trás né Você pode ser
muito bom mas me desculpe você tá para
trás aí ó acabou de responder com áudio
aí com áudio tá só carregando que minha
internet tá tá lenta que ela falou aqui
ó o primeiro acho que no processor F
minha internet aí
ó eu não tô conseguindo ouvir
É acho que não dá para ouvir né porque
não pega Ah já sei já sei já sei já sei
vai dar certo ó vou botar por aqui ó
Claro Mate
estou aqui para ajudar e que posso te
auxiliar hoje deu deu para escutar deu ó
olha que interessante Daniele perguntou
qual voz ela tá
usando ela tá usando a voz da Estela pô
que eu eu que eu clonei a voz da Estela
para poder clonar entendeu a voz dela
você pode botar a voz que você quiser
basta um áudio de um minuto o ideal de
um minuto eu usei menos né menos tempo e
aí você consegue copiar a voz você clona
pode ser a voz quem você quiser até sua
voz dá para você usar nos áudios é então
você pode usar a sua voz tá para você
enviar os áudios através da inteligência
artificial para seus pacientes Aine
perguntou essa programação é feita por
nós mesmos doutores não nós que fazemos
toda a parte de programação tá
certo aqui um outro áudio aqui ó ó
trabalha com a prescrição de hormônios
sempre priorizando a saúde e o bem-estar
quais desafios você tem enfrentado em
relação a sua saúde que o levaram a
buscar acompanhamento
médico muito bom tipo assim bem é bem
bem legal muito bom Dr far assim eles
fazem tudo só que eu como eu sou sou
engenheiro como eu sou engenheiro também
né Aí eu sou meio fuçado n eu gosto de
mexer nas coisas mas se eu tivesse
deixado eles fazer tudo sozinho era
teria dado mais certo eu fiz umas coisas
erradas aí no no
sistema sem problema dout PR gente
finalizar eu gostaria que você resumisse
a sua experiência com essa tecnologia em
uma frase né E qual seria essa
frase a frase a frase é nada é tão bom
que não posso ser melhorado Ah que minha
secretária dona neid é maravilhosa Tá
mas pode melhorar E por que não melhorar
por sério Sinceramente eu não tenho
objeção pessoal isso aqui vocês vão ver
que é barato pô é barato eu eu quando eu
fiz o Web eu pensei Falei pô vou gastar
50.000 com isso aqui eu falei mas fiquei
triste mas falei vou gastar quando eu
fiz a quando eu fiz a a chamada rapaz na
hora né Na hora né então assim vocês não
vão ter trabalho nenhum né com relação a
programação sistema nada disso tipo é
tudo muito intuitivo né Só se você
quiser né até se você quiser você pode
mexer no código né Tem essa
possibilidade mas não queiram não porque
porque dá trabalho tá V deixar com
pessoal que vocês pagaram é importante
que as pessoas saibam que a gente faz
tudo tá então muitas pessoas perguntaram
aqui eu que tenho que
programar eu posso como é que funciona a
gente que faz tudo tá a gente que
implementa tudo isso para vocês a gente
que entrega isso para vocês tá é é o que
a gente promete toda essa entrega feita
por nós tá Dr faran eu queria muito te
agradecer pela sua participação eu fico
muito feliz pelo seu resultado tão
rápido né então em poucas semanas você
já teve esse resultado expressivo né Eu
lembro quando a gente conversava e você
falava Estela pelo amor de Deus a minha
secretária Tô perdendo um
paciente então exato pô perdi uma grana
pô pela falta da ia uma grana então
assim esse esse esse esse faturamento
meu ele foi justamente por pacientes que
eram para ser meus e eu tava perdendo pô
entendeu Por isso não teve nada
extraordinário né Então isso que é o
legal é fico muito feliz e muito
obrigada por participar né Por topar tá
aqui com a gente tá muito muito muito
obrigada tá eu vou continuar aqui com o
pessoal tá certo obrigada doutor Valeu
show de bola tchau tchau eu também tô
por aqui ainda assistindo aprendendo com
você aí obrigado pode continuar
aí vamos lá pessoal Deixa eu voltar aqui
com vocês Tá então vocês viram o que
aconteceu com Dr faran vocês viram
também como é que a Iá ela funciona né
eu sei que tava ali um pouco embaçada a
apresentação mas vocês viram ali a
inteligência artificial dele funcionando
então sempre perguntando o nome né e a
gente prossegue ali sendo um paciente e
essa inteligência artificial ela vai ser
modelada de acordo com a sua situação no
caso do Dr far precisa ser perguntado
onde é que está esse paciente porque Ele
atende dois locais diferentes e
teleconsulta então a depender do que o
paciente ele responder a inteligência
artificial vai encaminhar né vai
responder vai dar continuidade de acordo
com aquilo que o paciente falou Tá certo
então vamos continuar
aqui Não Somente o Dr farani né ele não
é a única pessoa que teve resultado a
gente tem também aqui o consultório da
Dra Marcela Lemos que antes ela
conseguiria conseguia gerar 8200
contatos após a inteligência artificial
teve mais de
13.000 antes os seus agendamentos Iam em
torno de
754 após a inteligência artificial ela
foi para mais de 2.000 pessoas sendo
agendadas e de comparecimento mais de
1000 comparecimentos em relação a antes
que era de
243 tá e quais são as cinco principais
vantagens que você terá ao implementar
essa inteligência artificial dentro da
sua Clínica ou do seu consultório tá
então com as as inteligências
artificiais você vai ter uma secretária
que atende 24 horas por dia 7 dias por
semana tá e o que que a gente já
conseguiu mapear com os nossos clientes
59 dos atendimentos hoje acontecem fora
do horário comercial então você precisa
ter pessoas atendendo né Você precisa
ter pessoas ali conversando né uma
inteligência artificial conversando com
essas pessoas fora do horário comercial
Tá além disso você tem a velocidade
então falar com o contato no seu
primeiro minuto aumenta 400% a sua
conversão então nunca mais você vai ter
contatos né que vão ficar horas sem
respostas Além disso você tem resposta
em tempo real com todos os seus contatos
né então aqui é um caso Eh que que
sempre acontece né então pacientes
perguntando qual o valor da consulta
Então isso é você percebe que foi
perguntado ali 17 e9 e 17 e9 a
inteligência artificial Já
respondeu Tá além disso a inteligência
artificial ela entende áudio situações
delicadas conte melhor do que qualquer
secretária e nesse caso em específico né
o paciente ele enviou uma mensagem PR
Inteligência Artificial dizendo que
tinha um imprevisto n precisava remarcar
porque uma pessoa da Família tinha
falecido e essa foi a resposta da
Inteligência Artificial sinto muito pela
sua perda Gustavo minhas condolências a
você e a sua família nesse momento
difícil se precisar de alguma ajuda ou
quiser agendar a consulta Em outro
momento eu estarei aqui ajudar tá Isso
foi a resposta de uma inteligência
artificial então com a inteligência você
deixa de gastar dinheiro com mais
colaboradores ou seja com novas
secretárias que às vezes você à
acreditam que precisam contratar tá você
vai reduzir o número de pessoas vai
aumentar a sua eficiência como eu já te
mostrei vocês não vão precisar depender
de agência Afinal Vocês também vão ter
uma máquina de conversão e de atração de
pacientes que vai ser construída baseada
na sua situação na sua especialidade no
seu atendimento Tá certo e por último
todas as informações são 100% Integradas
com a sua agenda então a gente pergunta
também ali no final do atendimento as
informações necessárias para serem
passadas ali pro prontuário então nome
completo RG data de
nascimento e agora eu quero que você
entenda né eu quero na verdade se você
deseja saber como implementar todo esse
sistema em sua Clínica ou no seu
consultório então comenta aqui embaixo
para mim se vocês querem essa
inteligência artificial no seu
consultório comenta aqui Mateus falou
sim Ricardo falou sim Fran Falou sim sim
resposta é sim maravil então como éon
ação nós temos quatro fases aqui dentro
a primeira fase é uma fase de análise
onde a gente conhece né a sua Clínica
conhece o seu consultório tá então a
gente vai entender Quais são as suas
especificidades né O que que vocês TM de
diferencial a segunda fase nós vamos
implementar a máquina de atração de
pacientes para vocês a terceira fase a
gente vai implementar a inteligência
artificial que que converte os seus
pacientes e também fideliza esses
pacientes ó a galera falando sim Karina
sim Luciana sim Aline sim Adélia sim
Maravilha
pessoal o objetivo é que você tenha uma
máquina de pacientes particulares com
data e hora marcada todos os dias tá
então a gente tem a fase de análise onde
eu vou entender como funciona o
consultório atendimento quem são vocês
eu vou fazer todo esse eh esse apanhado
de informações depois de entender nós
vamos utilizar essas informações para
construir a sua máquina de atração de
novos pacientes e sua inteligência
artificial que é sua máquina de
converter pacientes e por fim você vai
ter uma máquina completa que agenda os
pacientes de forma automática para você
tá então como é que funciona o nosso
diagnóstico individual na primeira fase
do projeto a nossa equipe né ela vai
entender a sua situação como eu falei
então qual é a sua área Qual é o tipo de
paciente que você deseja receber quais
são as dores do seu público o que você
deseja ter dentro da sua inteligência
artificial e o que você não quer então
até esse nível de personalização a gente
faz tá nós vamos desenvolver aqui dentro
também guias para o seu público alvo O
que são esses guias Então hoje a gente
compreende endeu que uma forma muito
eficiente de retomar contato com aquelas
pessoas que estão na sua base Ou aquelas
pessoas que mandaram mensagem ali paraa
sua secretária e elas não agendaram a
consulta é através desses guias então
nós construímos ah guias baseados nas
principais queixas que os seus pacientes
que você atende tem e nós distribuímos
para eles como uma forma de retomar
esses contatos se vocês fossem
ah voltar ali com profissionais com
designers que criam esses guias esses
e-books seria pelo menos R 1.000 para
cada um desses guias tá que a gente
constrói Além disso né além da gente
construir todas essas máquinas vocês vão
ter a cada 30 dias uma análise com os
nossos especialistas
tá nós vamos construir toda sua máquina
de atração né então a máquina de atração
ela é responsável por atrair pacientes
para dentro do seu consultório tá então
você nunca mais vai precisar depender de
plano de saúde porque a gente também
fica responsável por atrair pacientes
para você além da máquina de pacientes
nós temos o sistema de
conversão você terá a melhor secretária
dentro do seu consultório e ela será
100% treinada de acordo com as suas
informações tá
bom além de você ter a atração de novos
pacientes
uma máquina de conversão que é a
inteligência artificial agendando esses
pacientes você terá um sistema de
fidelização que é responsável por
acompanhar os seus pacientes após a
consulta enviando a mensagem deixando
eles Apaixonados Pela experiência tá o
que vai gerar mais indicação para você
todos os dias então o que que uma
agência de marketing ela geralmente te
entrega ela vai te entregar um site né
um tráfego e vai enviar todas essas
pessoas para dentro de um WhatsApp mas o
que que nós fazemos nós entregamos
pacientes prontos agendados com data e
hora marcadas então nós temos que nós
atingimos três níveis de pacientes que a
gente divide aqui dentro então paciente
urgente aquela pessoa que já sabe que
precisa de ajuda o paciente
procrastinador que ela sabe que precisa
de ajuda mas ela procrastina em procurar
um médico e aquele paciente preventivo
que busca o médico né vai até o médico
porque ele quer se prevenir de algo a
gente capta todos esses pacientes e
coloca dentro da inteligência artificial
para agendar todos esses pacientes
agendados eles caem dentro de uma agenda
e após a consulta acontecer nós temos
toda a parte do pós-consulta entender se
aquele paciente tá bem o que que ele
precisa quando ele vai retomar né uma
nova consulta então a gente faz todo
esse tipo de acompanhamento com
inteligência artificial como é algo
muito individual eu não consigo nós não
conseguimos atender todos vocês então é
por isso que nós abrimos a cada se meses
com um valor
maior e é por isso que a gente vai
disponibilizar tá para vocês hoje a
oportunidade vocês conhecerem mais o
nosso a nossa implementação tá E para is
Vocês precisam responder um formulário
para ver se vocês estão aptos para que
vocês participem de uma reunião comigo
ou com o meu time para vocês conhecerem
mais tá bom então eu vou liberar aqui um
botão para vocês clicarem e preencher
esse formulário tá
bom deixa eu olhar
aqui pessoal tá liberado o
botão falando com o
time Cadê o
time Hum ainda não pera aí que o time
vai
liberar vamos lá
pessoal pode clicar nesse botão aí agora
Clica nesse botão e vocês vão conseguir
preencher o formulrio pra gente agendar
uma reunião e vocês conhecerem como
funciona a nossa
implementação Tá
certo falou que eu quero Adélia que eu
quero isso pessoal clica nesse
botão tá que nós vamos conseguir mostrar
para vocês como é que funciona toda essa
implementação a mesma implementação que
o Dr far implementou para resultados no
próprio consultório
tá Priscila falou que sim
também isso quem clicou comenta aqui no
no nos comentários quem já
clicou legal legal isso tem que
preencher o formulário
exatamente tá para que a gente possa
conhecer vocês dentro desse formulário e
ver se o seu consultório ele tá
preparado para implementar uma
inteligência artificial tá certo esse é
o motivo
principal o Joel perguntou vocês fazem
fazem tráfego pago dentro desse projeto
fazemos também tá
aá pode atender quantas especialidades
todas as especialidades Maria
se você se tiver que mudar algo na
programação vocês dão assistência por
quanto tempo 12 meses Maria um ano
inteiro tá
bom podem fazer perguntas também pessoal
então se vocês quiserem conhecer mais da
nossa implementação saber como
implementar isso dentro do seu
consultório para que vocês tenham Mais
resultados nos agendamentos na atração
de pacientes clique no botão tá clique
no botão para que vocês sejam levados
para essa reunião e a gente veja se o
seu consultório ele está preparado tá e
podem mandar perguntas aqui
também exatamente Aline nós precisamos
conhecer vocês entender qual situação
você está né para que a gente possa
entender como fazer essa implementação
dentro do seu
consultório tudo que a gente faz aqui é
personalizado tá
[Música]
podem fazer perguntas
pessoal exatamente a inteligência
artificial ela tem de todas as
especialidades E aí como é que nós
treinamos ela a partir das informações
que a gente colhe ali dentro daquele
diagnóstico que eu mostrei para vocês a
gente tem Qual a área que vocês atuam
qual o perfil de paciente que vocês
querem atrair como funciona seus seu
atendimento Qual o valor da sua consulta
nós construímos a inteligência
artificial do zero baseada nessas
informações que vocês passaram pra gente
então toda a construção é a gente que
faz tá bom E claro que vocês vão testar
Maravilha pessoal como vocês não tem
mais nenhuma dúvida eu quero convidar
vocês a a a preencherem esse formulário
tá vocês vão ter uma reunião comigo ou
com o meu time vocês vão entender
exatamente como funciona essa
inteligência artificial vocês vão
entender como é que a gente vai
implementar isso dentro do seu
consultório ou dentro da sua Clínica e
vamos entender como vai funcionar dentro
da sua
realidade Tá
bom então ó Aline perguntou já ia
finalizar se na clínica tiver
profissional Pode sim da áre
Odontológica eles podem se beneficiar
sim então a gente vai entender seu
cenário vai entender como funciona a sua
Clínica O que que tem dentro da sua
Clínica e sim
tá Luciana depende né de da sua situação
tá nós precisamos eh
entender mais sobre você e seu
consultório tá então se você tem essa
dúvida clica no formulário preenche
entra nessa reunião que a gente vai te
ajudar e tirar todas as suas dúvidas tá
bom pessoal muito obrigada tá por essa
por essa apresentação Dr farani também
muito obrigado tá
bom tchau
tchau Y